so we have some breaking news though
folks baito O'Rourke the former
congressman from Texas is dropping out
of the Democratic race does that make
you happy or sad well it makes me
certain that the boaters saw that he
wasn't really a credible candidate and
he was toast after the gun grab deal and
I feel like if I was a donor I'd be
wanting my money back we just had this
conversation about authenticity
comparing you know Hillary to Bernie and
beta was a perfect example of someone
that I just don't believe anything he
says he doesn't have that level of
authenticity when he speaks about things
and I think he went to extreme when he
was talking about the mandatory gun
buyback and I think it turned a lot of
people off so I'm not surprised I'm not
Greg I know that you were enchanted with
his appearance on Vanity Fair's yes that
was that was his downfall
was being anointed by people who were
just like him the white liberal editor
types believe me I know what the
election was for him it was a journey of
self-realization and we started to see
that that the fact that this was all
about him finding himself and everybody
was nauseated by he was like the world's
worst millennial and he's not I don't
even think he's a millennial but Dana
just looking at this from hardball
political perspective he did very well
in fundraising when he was running
against Ted Cruz in that Senate race in
Texas there was a great deal of
excitement about him as potentially a
new face for the Democratic Party young
man almost kennedy-esque you know
Camelot and all that so much of that
seems to have faded in this presidential
which is why a few weeks ago I said he
was a zombie candidate meaning that he's
dead he just doesn't know it yet in
terms of his candidacy um but just
remember it like so he raised a ton of
money and got a lot of attention and is
run up against Ted Cruz and he's still
lost by six points so why did they think
that he was going to be this great
savior and I think that he might have a
second or a third act you're going
forward but if you're running out of
money and you can't raise any more there
comes a point when you have to say I got
to cut this down I think this is the
beginning of the winnowing of this his
wife's family isn't filthy-rich I'm
really worried about what he's gonna do
next
why is he gonna get this healthcare yeah
when it came to those debate moments
where it came to his time to defend
himself defend his ideology he did
terribly at those things I think one of
the reasons that Bernie Sanders stays in
when you unity talked about his health
condition is because when he has to
defend his principles it seems like yes
it comes from a place of him actually
believing it but also he does a pretty
good job of battling the other people on
the on the debate floor and he bado
could not defend himself it looked like
he was reading somebody else's talking
points they had written for him all the
time that's might have knocked him out
at that last debate give me a chance to
read some bait oh here's bait Oh
O'Rourke again who dropped out of the
campaign today here's a tweet from him
he says quote our campaign has always
been about seeing clearly speaking
honestly and acting decisively in that
spirit I'm announcing that my service of
the country will not be as a candidate
or as the nominee Dana I just want to
come back to you there was there's a lot
of discussion about what's going on in
Iowa in terms of the polls and who was
going to get some of Sanders support as
same I'm Bernie starts to fade a little
bit but who gets beta or Rourke's
support as he leaves the race well he
doesn't have any support so it's hard to
say Carla Harris her campaign is laying
off staff and I think there was even
more announcement today like trying to
rearrange things again I think this is
like the beginning of the winnowing
because they just don't have support out
there but to the extent that there were
people out there that were for better I
think that if he is like the millennial
candidate I think the only candidate you
see this actually has some movement
right now is mayor Pete and if you're
not moving then you're probably stagnant
and dead in the water so he it probably
Falls to my peeps so the way that Dana
breaks it down Jesse what we've got is
Biden Sanders and Warren right well the
latest poll in Iowa came out and Biden's
in fourth place Wow it's Warren it's
Bernie
it's mayor Pete and then it's Joe Biden
and by a lot like those three are at the
top there's a big gap as you said and
I'd be very worried if I was Joe Biden's
campaign because he's also running out
of money so if you're not going to win
Iowa and maybe lose New Hampshire and
you don't have enough money then you
could see him really really start to
fade fast after the first tonight
we just heard right before we came out
here the Biden campaign is that they
raised six million dollars in October I
think the attacks against him probably
helped him in some well he should spend
some money investing in Iowa because he
can't lose if he loses he has to get
like a second or third if he gets fourth
place in Iowa that's that's not a strong
enough image to help I don't know that
it really ends his opportunity because
if you look at the national polls it's
not a no it wouldn't be a knockout he
extremely disappointed well and it could
give momentum to Elizabeth Warren